if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to 200 off and two
free pillows at
helixsleep.com
pacman
welcome everybody um most of you know
you know if you know me if you know my
show
you know i don't care about political
party yes i'm on the left and right now
that means i mostly vote for candidates
who happen to be democrats but i see
political parties aside from their
general platform and views on issues
really as organisms or entities that
seek to justify and perpetuate their own
existence they're not that different
from corporations in a lot of ways so i
don't care about defending democrats
when they do bad things i just call
things the way i see them
and today i have to call out joe biden's
white house press secretary jen saki and
every time i do this even though people
often write to me and say david i like
that even though you're on the left you
just tell it to us like it is as you see
it
when what i happen to see is someone on
the left not behaving correctly
sometimes people get mad and say david
you shouldn't be talking about this well
listen jen saki does some things well
and she does other things not so well
and early on in her press secretary ship
when she would be unprepared for a
question i would say it and then the
next time she'd be prepared and i would
say she was better prepared this time
and here is something that's really not
good a few days ago jen saki was asked
about
what about like maybe sending covid
tests to people's homes you know to stop
the spread the tests are not widely
available as much as we would like
they're expensive in many ways
what about sending people tests and she
kind of laughed it off scornfully by
saying what so we're just going to start
sending people free tests so let's look
at that video from a few days ago look
at what we've done over the course of
time we've quadrupled the size of our
testing plan we've cut the cost
significantly over the past few months
and this effort to
uh to push to ensure insurers are you're
able to get your your tests refunded
means 150 million americans will be able
to get free tests complicated though why
not just make them free and give them
out to and have them available
everywhere should we just send one to
every american
maybe then then what hap then what
happens if you if every american has one
test how much does that cost and then
what happens after that all i know is
that other countries seem to be making
them available for in greater quantities
for less money well i think we share the
same objective which is to make them
less expensive and more accessible right
uh every country is going to do that
differently and i'm just noting that
again our tests go through the fda
approval process it is absolutely true
that the united states has failed on
making at-home tests cheap and
accessible and getting them into
people's hands and
the answer is yes
send everybody tests wow that would be
an amazing thing to do consider what the
savings would be
given how expensive it is on average
for people to be hospitalized for covid
think about the savings now
i don't mean necessarily
send them to people who haven't even
asked for them there's no doubt that in
the us with the environment that we have
there are people who would receive the
tests and put them in the trash so i'm
not saying
just mail them out willy-nilly but set
up a website to send people free tests
and send them out when people request
them
but
she's right about one part
if we send each person one test what is
that really going to do that's true
which is why we should actually make it
easy for people to sign up and give them
five tests give them ten tests this is
how you get people who are exposed
regularly to identify cases early and
get them staying home
my sister right now has coveted she's in
high school
um
why
did she end up with it well part of it
is
there was a slow process for getting the
classmate who is believed to have been
the spreader
tested
and to report the results of that test
so
it's a great idea actually so a few days
go by and then jensaki gets another shot
at the same question and she does take a
different approach good for her she
seems to recognize that first answer was
a botched answer the problem is she ends
up reading a pre-written answer which is
a lot of words with very little meaning
take a look at her next answer to the
question is the white house's position
on this simply a cost analysis or are
there other reasons why the
administration doesn't think that
sending tests uh kobe 19 test to all
americans is a good strategy well let me
let me give you an overarching uh
comprehensive understanding of how we're
approaching this uh to give you a sense
and i appreciate the questions in
february we wrote new guidance to make
insurers cover asym asymptomatic pcr and
point-of-care tests critical to helping
the majority of americans who have
private insurance not worry about
burdensome test costs did we quadruple
the number of free pharmacy testing
sites with a priority on vulnerable
communities and we've also secured
funding from the rescue plan invested in
hardest hit areas 10 billion dollars for
schools to conduct testing nearly 1
billion dollars for rural clinics and
hospitals and toward the summer we also
plan for the school year ensuring school
districts had the resources to set up a
testing program to ensure kids stayed in
school we also doubled down our work to
get testing to congregate settings that
were more vulnerable and where demand
was was higher as we've seen at home
tests become more in demand we've taken
steps on that front to make them free so
if you have private insurance we're
making sure you'll get reimbursed by
your insurer for at-home tests all right
so you get the idea there's like another
minute but i'm not going to play it all
for you because it's this pre-written
not very substantive answer and it
became
since we aren't going to send people
free tests i'm going to read a bunch of
stuff for you that we've done which
doesn't include free tests and is not
going to include free tests there are
places that are doing the free testing
thing
monroe county new york is doing it to
some degree
um in colorado i believe if you have
kids in school
there's a way to get free tests in
seattle there's a test delivery system
and of course in other countries look at
what's happening in the uk
in terms of people's ability to get free
tests so
the good part is eventually gensake
figured out that first answer was no
good scornfully laughing off what we're
just gonna send people free tests yes
that was not good so she changed her
attitude
but she then came back with you know
something that clearly is not thinking
nearly big enough and a sort of
pre-written
answer communicating very very little
one of the ways that we can normalize
more to what we had before the pandemic
which the right wants to do
and
at least the biden administration wants
to be able to do in order to help the
economy and so on and so forth it's make
sure that we can easily figure out who
has covet and free testing would be a
major major piece of that it's funny
because her new answer the pre-written
two-minute answer that i played one
minute of for you
it is better in that it's less offensive
it's less
free tests get the hell out of here it's
less of that
but it doesn't actually get us anywhere
closer to just sending people free tests
which is abundantly clear they have no
interest in
or intention of doing so
she was prepared because she knew that
first answer was no good
but it doesn't seem like they're going
to do the free test guys and this is one
of the differences in a lot of other
countries the accessibility
and the low or no cost testing options
that are there
okay so
it's happening again
it happened to marjorie taylor green and
it is now potentially going to happen to
republican congresswoman lauren bobert
we have seen
numerous videos uncovered in which
lauren bobert implies or alludes to
muslim member of congress ilhan omar
being a terrorist
wearing backpack bombs refers to the
squad as the jihad squad and is
generally a gross person
as a result
uh some democrats are now moving to
strip lauren bobert of all of her
committee assignments is this a good
idea we're going to talk about it first
let's look at examples of what lauren
bobert has been saying i'm gonna play
three of them here for you she has told
a very similar story a few times
here are a few of those versions of the
story
now i've had a little bit of fun in
congress no i haven't gone toe to toe
with aoc she doesn't show up to work
sorry she votes by proxy
i did feel han omar the other day and i
said oh cute
the jihad squad decided to come in for
work
one of my staffers
on his first day with me got into an
elevator
in the capitol
and in that in the elevator we were
joined
by ilhan omar
well it was just us three in there and i
looked over and i said
well look in there it's the jihad squad
[Applause]
actually i have a new hot story for you
so uh the other night on the house floor
was not the my first jihad squad moment
uh so
i was getting into an elevator with one
of my staffers
and he and i are we're leaving the
capitol we're going back to my office
and we get an elevator and i see a
capitol police officer
running hurriedly
to the elevator i see fret all over his
face and he's reaching and i'm like
the door's shutting like i can't i can't
open it look what's happening
i look to my left and there she is
ilhan omar
and i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
so this is very vile stuff and as a
result massachusetts democratic
congresswoman ayanna pressley is moving
to have lauren beaubert removed from
every single committee on which she sits
pressly announced her resolution
yesterday morning let's take a look at
that clip
we have heard the hate and credible
threats that have been directed at rep
omar and her staff
words have consequences we must
acknowledge that and respond with action
we've introduced this resolution today
to do just that and to send a powerful
message to every muslim
and every marginalized person who has
ever questioned their place in this
country or in the halls of power
we see you
you belong
you are powerful
and you deserve a life free from fear
and filled with dignity and love
how we respond in moments like these
will have a lasting impact and history
will remember us for it now
i i have two views on this and i do want
to hear from you about it
on the merits if you just say does this
woman lauren bobert deserve to be on any
committees the answer is of course not
of course not on the merits she
shouldn't be on a single committee she
shouldn't be in congress i wouldn't
trust her to mow my lawn or uh uh
run anti-virus software on my computer
you know i don't want to minimize any
any job but what i'm saying even simple
jobs she has no business i wouldn't want
her doing anything oh david sir are you
saying she shouldn't earn a living guys
let's take it easy okay she's
incompetent
um her presence in the house of
representatives as a legislative body is
a disgrace
but to some degree
is it kind of a pyrrhic victory
when democrats do this
to these very much deserving of it being
done to them republican they did it to
marjorie taylor greene
now they're looking very strongly at
doing it to lauren bobert what do i mean
a pyrrhic victory a pyrrhic victory is a
victory
uh which
in so achieving the victory
you do damage to yourself or at the end
of the day you say i won but did i
really win did i really come out ahead
and what i mean by that is the following
republicans are not in the majority
right now regardless so democrats still
control
the committees
you are
stripping them whoever it is beau bert
marjorie taylor green you're stripping
them of their committee assignments
you allow them to claim victim status
you allow them to martyr themselves and
they immediately start raising money on
it i've been cancelled and so on and so
forth and i want to say it again so that
people don't misunderstand
it's not wrong to remove them it's right
beaubert has no business being involved
in anything in washington d.c
but what i'm wondering is what is truly
accomplished for example marjorie taylor
green within hours of being stripped of
her committee assignments she was
fundraising she was sending out
fundraising emails saying they've
canceled me
donate in order to help me
do whatever i don't even know what the
argument was but it was they've canceled
me and give me money so i'm not arguing
that it's the wrong move it's the right
move on the merits
but what i'm wondering is whether
we end up helping republicans more than
hurting them when we do this to them
because they go to i've been canceled
and i told you that democrats cancel
people and now you've got to help me get
uncanceled for beau bert it's almost a
dream scenario
uh less work
she gets talked about in right-wing
media
it gives her something to fundraise on
so what really needs to happen is she's
removed from congress that's a much
tougher
and certainly much longer uphill battle
so let me know what you think net
benefit
or not
when these folks are removed from their
committee assignments
remember also tuesday december 14th 6
p.m eastern will be the next david
pakman show viewer town hall it will be
the last town hall of the year i hope
you'll join us it'll be streaming live
on the pacman live youtube channel
that's the second channel
very much looking forward to it
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is you
don't have to guess which mattress do i
need which one will be good for me you
take their famous sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so
don't get stuck with something that's
not perfect for you and all helix
mattresses come with a 10-year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days if you
don't love it but i think you will all
of my viewers will get up to 200 off
your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video i want to take a second just
to thank uh everybody who has signed up
on our website this week i told you at
the start of the week it's been a
tougher few months as far as membership
goes and we had this
uh idea anybody who signs up for a full
price yearly membership will send you a
free t-shirt if you would like it and a
bunch of people have taken advantage of
it and i can't tell you how much i
appreciate it you can sign up at
joinpakman.com very easy to do you can
use um you can you can use a coupon code
you can get a monthly membership a
yearly membership the coupon code is
better21 if you would like a free
t-shirt with your membership
you've got to do a year and full price
the 60 bucks you know we're trying to
raise money not lose money
and if you do that you can email info
davidpakman.com after signing up just
let us know your mailing address and the
t-shirt style size and color
that you would like three important
details
um and we will get that right out to you
free with your full price yearly
membership or get a discounted monthly
two bucks a month very very good deal
guys joinedpakman.com really appreciate
everybody's support oh we have a david
pakman show subreddit which you could
find at davidpakman.com reddit a nearly
34 000 of our viewers and listeners have
signed up so far some interesting posts
i spotted this morning that i want to
take a look at with you first is about
putin trump and russia
and it says putin poised to invade
ukraine
trump probably gnashing at the bit so he
can point his demonic finger at biden's
failure to prevent putin would love this
support from his wannabe fellow tyrant
yeah there's going to be this amazing
double standard that takes place maybe
not from i mean trump will say something
but who cares right but from from people
on the right
where
all along during the trump
administration they said hey guys we
want to be friends with russia
why you want to go to war war is bad now
we now pretend not to like war let's all
get along putin's nice putin's good all
this different stuff
and then
if putin does invade ukraine
those very same people will say why
wasn't biden tougher
why is biden beta why is biden weak it's
going to be an amazing double standard
and i i would say i look forward to it
but it's actually horrifying quite
frankly
but yeah we're going to be watching the
reaction from the right including trump
about what ultimately happens there
next post i spotted which was
interesting hey david do you think it's
likely cinema and mansion are being
being blackmailed
wouldn't put it past a significant
percentage of the republican party who
has proven themselves to be willing to
do anything to subvert biden to
blackmail two members of the democrats
in order to stop meaningful legislation
from passing you know that's not
typically the way things work in the
senate usually in the senate they don't
use blackmail which is more of like the
stick
they use the carrot which is here's the
stuff we'll give you
if you
do or don't go along with this or
whatever the case may be
um and that's more frequently the way
that the way that it works
rather than here's what we're gonna go
here's what we're gonna do to you
if you do the wrong thing it's here's
what we'll give you if you do the right
thing and of course you could say these
are legalized bribes it's a form of
bribe so blackmail i think less likely
goodies
as donald trump like to say
more
more probable
another user posted
an article
about a let's go brandon store that
opened in the state of or the
commonwealth as donald trump likes to
say of massachusetts
i don't know
too much about right wing memes i know
that let's go brandon is a big one right
now
this can't possibly last too much longer
can it like i already feel like you know
the way i gauge what the right is
obsessed with
is
what kind of gutter trash my live stream
live chat is filled with
and a few weeks ago it was filled with
people just posting let's go brandon
over and over again in all caps
and of course we were banning every
single one of them
and um we're seeing a lot less of it
right now in the comments in general so
it feels as though let's go brandon is
already kind of dying down but if it's
not
it's such a lame meme that i can't
imagine it would last too much longer
and i think if you're just now opening
up the let's go brandon store
it doesn't seem like particularly
auspicious timing that's that's my
instinct but let me know if it's going
to have staying power as the case may be
join the discussion on the subreddit
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t
so we we've already done an expose
of fox news's hypocrisy on vaccine
requirements on air
we've got the fox hosts in particular
tucker carlson laura ingram
hannity entertaining this stuff as well
the daytime shows
uh dan bongino you know the whole crew
they've been softly and sometimes not so
softly pushing against vaccines
promoting unproven treatments and cures
certainly against the vaccine
requirement very aggressively against
them and yet
behind the scenes we learned that fox
news has an even stricter vaccination
policy than the one that joe biden
proposed you've got to not only be
vaccinated but if you aren't you've got
to be testing daily rather than weekly
and you've got to be wearing a mask okay
we talked about it already we know about
the fox news hypocrisy but what about
newsmax because newsmax the even further
right network
has been completely off the rails
in an even wackier way than fox news on
vaccines coveted and coveted related
conspiracies and it turns out
that this week newsmax had a holiday
party in new york city
and yes everyone had to present proof of
vaccination in order to attend a
negative test alone would not suffice
you must show your vaccination card or a
picture of your vaccination card here's
the notice that newsmax sent out which
says reminder on newsmax holiday
reception
city regulations require that you show a
vaccination card a coveted test alone is
not sufficient now newsmax made
completely clear that as a company
they have no vaccine requirement
whatsoever
this is a requirement for this
particular holiday party because it's in
new york city and these are new york
city rules but wouldn't you think that
if this goes against their principles if
they are so opposed to any such
requirements wouldn't they
put their money where their mouth is and
stand in defiant opposition have the
party in some other state
have the party at a private residence
find some way around it like it doesn't
seem like it would be that hard right
now in their defense and you know i have
no interest in i want to encourage good
behavior not just call out bad behavior
newsmax has parted ways with a couple of
the wackier anti-vaxxed people that
they've had on air there's this guy
steve cortes
former trump advisor
he recently left the network as a
primetime host for example
and
he was very publicly against newsmax
vaccine rules and sources told the daily
beast that it was because of that loud
opposition to his employer's own rules
it was sort of the last straw steve
cortez and newsmax parted ways we talked
three weeks ago maybe it was more like
four or five weeks ago the white house
correspondent emerald robinson from
newsmax she was in bonkers cuckoo for
coco puffs land tweeting about
bioluminescent tracking devices in the
vaccine and what else was she talking
about
luciferase and um
you something did she talk about a
blacklight i don't even remember anyway
she is not coming back to the network
after her completely off-the-wall claims
about the vaccine so good for newsmax as
far as that goes i've actually had a
couple of
very polite exchanges with some some
higher ups at newsmax
um
they're not obviously crazy it does seem
like it's for money meaning it's it's
sort of a grifty thing that newsmax is
operating
maybe i'll say more about that in the
future i don't want to sort of out
anybody there
but uh newsmax clearly not standing in
opposition strongly enough to vaccine
requirements to say
we're going to a private residence or
we'll do it in i don't know what the
rules are in new jersey but maybe we'll
do it over the river in new jersey or
somewhere else
they are just going with the rules and
um it is not a shock given what we've
seen fox news do and all of these other
complete and total hypocrites let me
know your thoughts about that we'll have
more coverage of this on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman's
show we will take a quick break
a lot of exciting things coming up on
the program in mere moments
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program today congressman ro khanna
representing california's 17th district
which includes silicon valley joining us
today from a car
uh very much great great to have you
back on
david a park
um so okay supply chain shortages gas
prices
uh tchotchkes from china that are
expected to be christmas gifts you know
there's this there's this broad range of
what does milk cost what do toys cost
etc initially there was the idea that
this is
a uh a demand resurgence after there was
a demand uh evaporation during the
pandemic it's now pretty clear that it's
more than that but what's your kind of
general assessment of what we're seeing
right now
well we're seeing inflation and this is
why
we need two things we need to pass
billbag better which would put more
money in the pockets of working families
so that they could pay for their
groceries and gas it would lower
prescription drug
prices it would deal with some of the
supply chain issues by investing money
in our ports by providing an incentive
for people to uh
return to uh return to work uh and so
we we need to pass it and then the fed
you know as larry summers has said the
fed uh needs to
to make sure that they stop in my view
the mortgage buybacks and stop
increasing the money supply
that's largely on the fed
and they can take that action
let's pick one item which is gas prices
because it gets so much attention you
know for years i have not participated
in the
you either blame or praise the president
for what's going on with gas prices
my best assessment is if a president
wants they can tap into the strategic
reserve which
will eventually lower gas prices maybe
18 to 20 cents a gallon on what might be
a temporary basis i mean it seems really
that presidents don't have very much to
do with gas prices but yet it's a very
popular political football to throw
around isn't it
well this president i think did the
right thing by uh having tapping the
strategic patrol and reserve 18 cents
per gallon is uh significant i mean that
means a lot to folks who are who are
struggling
but in terms of dramatically lowering
prices it uh has more to do with the oil
companies i mean they didn't when when
oil was 22 30 bucks a barrel they didn't
invest now that it's uh much higher
they're
they they want to reap the benefits and
so the long-term solution to this is
price stability which is more electric
vehicles more renewable energy so that
we're not dictating
we're not at the mercy of the vagaries
of the price of oil uh but uh in the
short term i think president biden's
taking the right action
when you when we look at some of some
other things like for example uh used
cars have been a big area of price
increase starting with the pandemic and
continuing through building materials is
another one although it seems that
lumber is sort of coming back down
how involved do you believe a government
should be on individual areas like these
in trying to influence price
as involved as we can be i mean we have
to be realistic that the governments
usually
don't have that many tools to to fight
inflation i mean it goes back to
gerald's fort with wind and whip
inflation and you know it's very hard to
do but we should do what we can in this
case i think the three things we need to
do is put more money in the pockets of
working families so that they have money
to deal with the higher prices make sure
we're dealing with supply chain issues
at the ports and make sure we're
incentivizing more people to work so
that
you can deal with some of these supply
issues and lower prices i guess i'd have
one more thing which is if there's
concentrated industry uh making sure
people aren't charging uh prices above
the competitive price and uh putting
pressure on those industries to charge a
fair price
there's uh i guess we would call it
plausible maybe we don't have to say
probable yet that republicans may well
take control of the house of
representatives back next year and and
would assume control in january of 2023.
given that we don't know at least what
will happen after next november
what do you believe realistically can
get done in terms of major legislation
in the next year
that that would pass not only the house
but actually the senate and become law
well first of all we need to make sure
we win or it's a devastating for
our democracy i mean to have people like
marjorie taylor greene and others
in charge of the house of
representatives is a fake that
really no one in my view and the
democratic side should should want and
shouldn't take uh should take very
seriously i i think we have to obviously
we have to pass buildback better which
will lower prescription drug costs lower
child care costs lower elder care costs
we need to in my view deliver on the 15
minimum wage the president can
unilaterally forgive student loans he
ought to do
that have some forgiveness of student
loans voting rights we have to deliver
voting rights this is our
chance to do it or we're basically stuck
with state
voter suppression laws uh and we need to
make sure that we're
tackling immigration i mean if it
doesn't make it into build bag better
there has to be some delivering uh on
immigration so those would be some of
the things i think that are the
priorities for next year on on student
loans i get a lot of emails from people
who say i'm really mad that joe biden is
not moving more quickly on forgiving
some student loan debt i came into this
presidency not believing that joe biden
had any intention of doing that i'm not
i'm not praising or or saying i'm mad at
him i just never thought that this was a
priority for joe biden i didn't think he
was going to forgive any student debt
is that your view or do you think that
that's something he might be able to be
pressured to do
i think he should be persuaded to do it
i think it could help really build
support uh in
with him with young people around the
country and it's the right thing to do
uh and he understands that we're being
married to
the first lady who's a an educator how
much debt we're saddling the younger
generation with now i don't think he's
going to do 50 000 as senator warren
senator schumer and i and others have
asked but could he do 10 20 000 and
would that materially make a difference
in people's lives absolutely and i i
think it would be one of the biggest
things he could do to build momentum for
his presidency
you mentioned marjorie taylor greene as
some in my audience know the house voted
to stripper of her committee assignments
uh some months ago
uh your colleague ayanna pressley has
now
suggested uh proposed doing the same
with with lauren beaubert over her
multiple recent videos related to
stories about being in elevators with
ilhan omar and the jihad squad etc uh
are when what's your view about doing
that because it's obviously correct on
the merits and i would go further that
these folks have no business even being
in the house of representatives but is
it not a pyrrhic victory in some sense
where they end up saying i've been
cancelled to donate money and it gives
them attention well david you're
actually right i was talking to a friend
of mine on the republican side yesterday
and he said when are you going to kick
me off my committee so i can go raise a
million bucks i got an email to my uh
my list so this is why i think the
speaker is being judicious about this
discussing it obviously we have to take
action it has to be clear that that kind
of racism that kind of islamophobia has
no place but we don't want to make
representative barbara martyr uh and and
do something that's going to further
fuel uh her platform and that's
why i think the speaker's taking her
time consulting the caucus i will
support uh whatever action she ends up
taking we do need to take some action
behind sometimes we learn that
there are interesting political
bedfellows behind the scenes where
publicly there's a lot of conflict and
they're friends behind the scenes
uh right now with some of these
personalities that exist for example
this rift between congresswoman beauberg
and and ilhan omar
is there more palpable tension behind
the scenes where it is not nearly as
collegial as it tends to be
i think on some of the fringes yes there
are a few people who probably
you don't uh interact with you don't
even sometimes say hi to
but not among the vast majority i mean i
still have
good relations on the other side i was
speaking i speak often to representative
calmer we disagree strongly on issues of
oil and gas other issues but he's
always engages in good faith there are
you know dozens of members on the other
side who i still work with you have to
get legislation through
i want to talk a little bit about um the
general approach that you think the
democratic party should take going into
the 2022 election one of the things that
makes it increasingly tough to run
against the kind of modern republicans
of the trump and post-trump era is for
the most part they're not even
pretending to be about policy anymore
they're about obstruction they're about
cultural issues like critical race
theory or a christmas tree was burned
and it's part of the war on christmas or
whatever the case may be so that's very
silly but it also makes it sort of tough
to run against them because if they're
not arguing on policy it's hard to fight
against things like the left wants to
turn this country into a socialist
country or these kind of vague
statements so how do you run against
that i i'm not convinced that just
continuing to talk about policy like a
train
is actually is is what's effective
well we lead with patriotism we talked
about how uh we have an aspirational
vision for america we have a vision in
america where uh we actually win the
21st century we're proud of being
americans everyone should be taught to
be uh proud of being americans and what
we want to make sure is people shouldn't
have to be forced to leave their
hometowns we need to bring prosperity
uh and and modern opportunity to places
that have long uh been left out so that
they could have dignity so they can stay
kids can stay with their families and
that you know trump promised all these
things but he hasn't delivered and we
will to to build a strong vibrant great
america uh i think we don't emphasize
the patriotism enough the aspiration
enough you have to get to people's
hearts to get them to think yeah they
really have a vision that they care
about this country they care about my
community
and then you can get into the specifics
but you can't lead with the specifics
without
what is the end what is uh what is the
purpose human beings aren't just
economic actors yeah that's what seems
extraordinarily difficult about the
situation which is
i feel very strongly that when there is
a policy debate we win the policy debate
very clearly but if the if the
circumstances don't allow you to be
speaking to a public that is expecting
to have the policy debate and instead
they want the debate over who is
socialist or patriotic or whatever the
case may be it feels like a losing
battle in some sense
well we can win that debate that our
values are the true
american values our values of the
freedom of ideas and expression of
respect for people of all faiths of a
respect for a community of uh civility a
decency uh these are the american values
that we're standing up for in the
fulfillment of those values and of
spreading opportunity and prosperity i
think we ought to frame them as uh we're
standing up for the
deepest uh american values the
fundamental american values and not that
we're here's our five-point plan uh just
to put more money in your pocket that
matters but people care uh holistically
they want to see our nation thrive and
succeed and they want to know what their
place is in this nation and we have to
speak to that deeper aspiration that
people have and and people are very much
vote on identity
before i let you go um i'm curious now
in thinking about 2022 of course every
member of the house is up for
re-election many in very safe seats so
the number of truly contested seats is
of course only a fraction of the total
um one-third of the senate is is of
course up there's a number of governors
races etc how much talk behind the
scenes is there about the role that the
former president donald trump is going
to try to play either in general in the
midterms or in in specific races and
does it really matter in terms of the
strategy for democrats
i do think he's going to play a role
he's already playing a role in georgia
challenging an incumbent governor he's
challenging some sitting house members
uh i i think it it provides an
opportunity for democrats to when the
republican party is so divided and
they're uh still having people who are
denying joe biden's legitimate election
uh running for office on that platform
but i don't think it's sufficient for
democrats i think uh it gives us an
opportunity
to compete to not be written off uh to
maintain our majority but we have to
have a vision that delivers for people
and that convinces them that we really
are speaking to what what matters to
them and matters them not just
economically matters to their conception
of our country and only if we do that
can we can we keep the house do you
think the virginia gubernatorial from
last month was a warning about making it
too much about running against trumpism
because young can seem to kind of
ride the fence well enough that it was
not a good strategy
yeah i don't think it should be all
about trump i think it could be also
about some of the extremes in congress
who basically said look do you want some
of these people to be cheering the next
committees and to be
in charge of the the new congress but
then i think it has to be a clear vision
on our side of what we have delivered
what we're going to continue to deliver
what we stand for people
ultimately need the positive the
affirmative to vote for someone yeah the
the more i look at next year the more
i'm of the mindset of
hope for the best and and prepare for
the worst and hopefully it works out not
not too poorly congressman ro khanna
representing california's 17th district
always appreciate your time
thank you david i always enjoy being on
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow many of donald trump's
recent interviews are so short form
where he gets such little time to really
flesh out his bonkers answers there's
just sort of less of an opportunity for
him to hang himself with his own rope
and don't get me wrong like he still
looks like a fool if you look at that
recent interview he did with mark levin
he did admit to crimes specifically
obstruction during the interview
completely unprovoked so he's not coming
off like an angel in those interviews
but i have a new interview from this
week that's a little bit different where
trump was allowed to sort of go longer
maybe less constrained because it was on
newsmax than by the sort of fast-paced
nature of the fox news interview um you
might know that sean spicer one of
donald trump's former press secretaries
now has a show on newsmax and trump
appeared on that show and he got an
opportunity to answer different types of
questions and not only is he sort of
slurring up a storm and sounding
disoriented as often as the case he's
making no sense in terms of the
substance either and telling countless
lies but lies that are important why but
because they signal
trump's plan for 2022 and maybe even for
2024 in terms of republican strategy and
in terms of his involvement so let's
look at the first clip the topic of
trump's social media company truth
social comes up we talked on the bonus
show earlier this week
um donald trump hired congr republican
congressman from california devin nunes
to run it devin nunes is going to be
resigning from congress in order to run
trump's social media company
and immediately trump is bomb throwing
when asked about the fact that there's
an ethics investigation into devin nunes
of course there's ethics investigations
into many members of congress some
republicans some democrats there's
nothing particularly pernicious about
this one but immediately trump is bomb
throwing take a look at this apparently
according to other reports say he's
already looking at that company so can
you comment on on devin nunes's role and
the sec
well i don't know anything about the sec
i do know that devin is fantastic
and i guess we just put out a release
and the release says that he'll be
coming on
and you know this is just a continuation
of witch hunts anything you do
they want to look at it they look at it
they don't look at themselves they don't
look at hunter they don't look at
anybody all they do is look at
republicans devin is a fantastic guy i
think that he will do a an incredible
job if our side doesn't have a voice
eventually you're not going to have
you're going to end up with pure
communism it's a disgrace what's going
on but you're going to end up with a
communistic
communist nation
and so uh devin we just put out the
release on devin we're very proud of
that we're proud of him
and uh
i think it's got a chance of being
a very important
day actually i think it's going to be a
very important day always a victim
devin nunes is a victim
the right are victims of the social
media left wing
everybody's communists on and on and on
now hilariously this entire interview as
as are many of the ones trump has been
doing lately are supposedly to promote
trump's book
the thing about trump's book is that
it's a picture book which is just
amazing and in this next clip i'm going
to play for you they have to suck up to
trump they always do
and sean spicer sucks up to trump by
saying we understand you wrote all of
the captions for the book
because remember
it's a picture book most presidents
writing books trump instead
publishing a picture book in which he
writes the captions it's beyond parody
but the topic is
trump's opinion of what mike pence did
on january 6. take a look
you know mr president in the book
there's a picture of you with vice
president pence and you talk about the
caption that you wrote and i understand
you wrote all the captions on these
photos says that you got along great
except on one issue vice president pence
on thursday said that he did the right
thing on january 6. in your mind did he
do the right thing and is that obviously
the one thing that you didn't agree with
him on
uh totally and he didn't do the right
thing and he's
a person who's a good person he didn't
have the he didn't do whatever
it is that you might say he should have
done because and i think you agree with
me and a lot of people agree with me
if you see that the election was
fraudulent if you see that there are
more votes than there are voters if you
see many of the things that went along
and and they're they're coming out on a
weekly basis more and more and more and
you'll be seeing more come out it's not
me it's
states now look at what's going on in
pennsylvania they're sending subpoenas
to many people and now the federal
government will try and stop that
because they don't want that to happen
they got away with something that is in
my opinion the crime of the century and
instead of going after antifa and blm
and all these people that killed a lot
of people and burned down our cities and
what they did the destruction they're
going after
people that were protesting the election
the election was the insurrection the
november third date was the insurrection
the january sixth date was not the
insurrection that was the protest this
is really stunning stuff
trump is still saying it was pence's
choice not to do what he could have done
to steal the election from the guy who
really won it and as we've heard from
numerous legal scholars pence could not
have done anything to steal it
pence realized he couldn't steal the
election
and he wasn't going to make any kind of
buffoonish attempt to try
and that was the right perspective pence
sought legal counsel on that and the
legal advice was very very much sound
the other notable thing about this is
that trump has stopped even pretending
that the violence on january 6th was bad
or that it was carried out
uh by his supporters he wants to play it
both ways
trump's new story which he seems to be
sticking with is
the insurrection was the november
election
i really won and they did an
insurrection and they stole it and it
led to joe biden being declared the
winner that that was the insurrection
per trump
january 6th on the other hand that was a
protest it was a logical protest because
the election was stolen it was a
peaceful protest by my supporters trump
supporters
but any violence that there was was
black lives matter and it was antifa of
course a claim for which there is
absolutely no evidence
and despite that it is trump supporters
that are being treated poorly that's not
only an inaccurate revision of history
it's a very dangerous one
because if it convinces many people and
it's convincing quite a few
it is part of this possible next coup
attempt that we talked about on
yesterday's program
then and this is the last clip that
we'll look at although if this is
interesting if you can stomach this i
encourage you to find the entire
interview it's available online
trump then does his routine
of stating states in which he did very
well he sort of stopped sort of saying i
won these states but they're states
where we did well
and these are states trump is looking at
being involved in in 2022 and so this is
actually massively consequential and
we're going to talk about why in a
moment but first let's look at the clip
than most but uh we won uh
big numbers in missouri and you didn't
mention ohio where we'll also be
involved but we have time i mean it
won't be there won't be primaries for
quite a while in all of those states and
we have some time interesting things
going on in this place that i love is
pennsylvania you have a lot of very
interesting candidates in pennsylvania
too so we're going to be involved in the
process yeah
okay mr president congratulations on the
book uh our journey together is out
tomorrow it's available at 45books.com
as always your time uh is greatly
appreciated and thank you for honoring
us well thank you both very much and
keep up the good work you're doing great
thank you thank you
thank you sir so
why is this so important
it's important because this is the
clearest signal yet from trump that he
will be involved in 2022 races and he
mentions missouri
he mentions pennsylvania maybe he's
going to support dr oz in pennsylvania
and he mentions some other states
now
this is a signal from trump about his
intentions the question that remains
is whether the candidates want donald
trump involved
but if he can raise money for them
i imagine they are certainly going to
let him do it
and without a doubt trump's preference
would be be involved
endorse and campaign for people who win
and use those successes if it happens to
justify running in 2024 and being the
republican nominee by saying look at
what i did for us in the midterms that's
his plan he's making it very clear right
now and it very much might work
now on the other hand of things that
might work versus might not work
we now are seeing almost daily
installments in this confusing
bizarre kind of aimless republican civil
war but today we have a new wrinkle
the republican civil war has mostly been
anti-trump republicans
and pro-trump republicans fighting each
other
like i said earlier this week
this is a civil war we want to encourage
it's a good thing for this to be going
on
yesterday's episode we had dan crenshaw
sort of a fence rider continuing to ride
the fence and tread water in the midst
of the civil war saying uh well you know
um the freedom caucus people who claim
to be very pro-trump they didn't really
vote with trump that much but people
like adam kinzinger who is seen as
anti-trump actually did vote for trump
dan crenshaw finding a way to ride the
fence that was yesterday
today there's a new wrinkle and now it
is just straight-up trumpest on trumpist
civil war today we have
trumpian lawyer lynn wood that's the
same guy who briefly represented kyle
rittenhouse and that's relevant
lynnwood is also the guy who was
involved in all sorts of 2020 election
high drinks that very same linwood
trumpian lawyer
attacking brutally
trumpian congresswoman marjorie taylor
green even within the pro-trump wing of
the republican party there is now
trouble in paradise and we should
encourage this
we should foment this
lynn wood is now accusing marjorie
taylor green
of being under the influence of not not
alcohol
of the devil
after kyle rittenhouse claimed that
linwood exploited him to make money
marjorie taylor green tweeted quote lynn
should go to jail for what he did to
kyle i also fully blame him for why
georgia lost our senate seats
he's from georgia and we know him as a
lifelong democrat
not a republican he grifted off of trump
and told people not to vote on january
5th
saying their vote would be stolen
lynn wood
has now gone to the daily beast and said
he's thinking about suing marjorie
taylor green for defamation suing fox
news propagandist tucker carlson for
defamation and he responded to this by
saying quote i mean from a biblical
perspective
i think she's under the influence of the
devil because people that follow jesus
christ don't lie marjorie taylor green
is a liar
draw your own conclusions
linwood also told the daily beast green
was one of a number of deep state
right-wing agents working to destroy his
credibility
not a surprise there so when the lunatic
extremists are fighting each other you
know that all is not well in their world
and i take two interests in this one you
already know this type of infighting can
only be good for the left it might not
help the left but it might and it
certainly doesn't help the pro-trump
right
if the left knows how to take advantage
of it but the more interesting piece is
that this is yet another data point that
what unites these people fundamentally
is not actually even support for donald
trump
um there was one layer which was these
are all republicans and what unites them
is conservative values no the pro-trump
republicans had completely different
values it's just trump says i'm a
republican so they vote for republicans
fine so that that we were done with well
maybe it's support for trump that
actually unites them no
lynnwood and marjorie taylor greene both
claim to love trump they both support
trump they both say trump is great lynn
wood claims trump actually won the
election marjorie taylor greene claims
trump actually won the election
lynn wood wants to take the election
back however they can
marjorie taylor green wants to take the
election back however they can both
believe kyle rittenhouse acted in
self-defense you get the point
but
as soon as there's anything but complete
deference to each other personally
they go to war the deep state this the
devil that you're subject to this even
the very trumpism that supposedly unites
them is not enough to go beyond the
personal for these folks it's a complete
and total grift and the question is
whether the left will figure out how to
take advantage of it and actually win
some elections unfortunately i remain
very skeptical that the left actually
knows what to do with this we'll talk
about what the left could do with this
on an upcoming show
if you have ideas certainly let me know
i have some but always interested in
hearing from you
hey this is really funny uh we have a
voicemail number the number is 219 to
david p
the other day on one of my live streams
one of our viewers pointed out you know
omicron
can be it has an anagram which is
moronic
i don't know what the meaning of that
was but the guy eric from mass who told
me that
wanted it to mean that we just shouldn't
even pay attention to omicron fine
today's caller
found an even more pernicious anagram
take a listen to this
david sir
this is
corey from indianapolis yes i
saw on your live stream
last week i think it was a super chat
mentioned that omicron is an anagram for
moronic it's that it's it's omicron not
omnicron but yes
i realized something far more sinister
which is that the word delta omicron is
an anagram for media control right
so i think this might go a little deeper
than we previously thought yes and and i
i checked it out for myself
it's delta omicron not delta omnicron
but it is a perfect anagram for media
control
what it actually means
i couldn't tell you but at least
conceptually some very suspicious stuff
going on we have a great bonus show for
you today become a member folks sign up
at joinpackman.com become a member and
you'll get instant access to today's
bonus
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors if you're looking
for a mattress go with helix sleep their
two-minute sleep quiz will tell you
which mattress is perfect for you you'll
get up to two hundred dollars off and
two free pillows at helixsleep.com
pacman